all right Mike the important question
the last movie big movie that you really
did not like sports movie no I am Oh
sports sports movie that I didn't like
it's tough
you guys are talk about Sandlot in the
last the last segment yeah yeah okay
nothing nothing special I there are many
sports yeah I am NOT a big movie guy at
all I mean I will I'll be one of those
people when people start quoting movie
lines I just like hey I'm out cuz I
don't go too many movies um give me a
minute or two or that sport movie sports
movie that I didn't like what's a sports
movie you love that might surprise
surprise you I like all the classics
like losers you know that's probably one
of my one of my go-to movies I I love
all the you know I watch slap shot a
while ago that actually was a very funny
movie for a variety for a variety
reached I was just a kid - aw - so I'm
not I am I swear dad I am probably the
bottom of the barrel when it comes to
movie buffs of anybody who's ever been
on the show if I said better room better
golf movie tin copper County show
Caddyshack caddie see there are too many
classic moments in lines ahead of tin
cup don't agree yeah you know no no I
you know Rene Russo is in tin cup and
and that's that's that's enough I love
Rene Russo for you yeah a little bit is
it the ability to associate with the
know take a sleeve of balls and I'm
gonna clear the hazard type feel for
that I think so but would that would
that happen that's happened in real life
with Jon Daly hasn't it is funny when
Rory McIlroy was coming out there was a
producer who at that point gave me his
name in my ear I could couldn't say Rory
McIlroy and called him Roy McAvoy
early on in my career that every time
Rory is play I'm like here's rory
mcilroy I was laughing to myself that's
all I could think of great moments in
television history did tin cup come out
before Jean Van de Velde meltdown yes
yesterday give Andy Bell was 99 that's
why I'm almost sure that was before
before I'm looking at man perfect I'm
standing right above the Barry burn as I
speak to you where he went in when
rolled eyes rolled up his pants no no I
show has a lot of a lot of cred but I
think if I told the R&A hey guys can I
just stand in the middle of 18 well
while I do this head for dance show I
don't think I wasn't saying that you
roll up your pants
I was letting people know Jean Van de
Velde rolled up his pants and was going
to play a shot do you know he's a on
course commentator for French TV this
week oh well he's an expert you know if
somebody has to lay up we'll go right to
John our correspondent I don't know if I
could do that could you come back to
this place and just be at the open and
kind of face it and live that I know
it's 19 years he's talked about it a lot
his attitude has been very much look you
remember me because what happened
probably more than you would have
remembered me if I would have won and
then done nothing else but I don't know
if I could come here and just be right
in the middle of all this and not just
you know worry myself sick ass or what I
didn't do
19 years ago yeah but you were there
doing you were hosting you were going to
play by play with Curtis Strange so you
know you were I saw the special on Golf
Channel as you guys look back upon that
I think the one thing that I didn't
realize is Jean Van de Velde was melting
down right in front of us but he I think
there was part of him that loved the
attention then oh like he was saying he
was a performer he would rather go down
as a performer and may lose than to play
it conservatively and there was nothing
about him that was boring and I think
that that that actually hurt him and his
approach to that final hole and and I
think it's the reason that he has been
able to embrace what happened as opposed
to be crushed by it
in terms of look his golf life was done
at that point yet he has spoken about it
when one asked to do interviews more
times than not he has given interviews
and given good interviews as well so
it's a it's an interesting approach that
he had to the game to life to everything
that I think it helps him come through
it and you might be right it may have
cost him his chance to succeed in that
moment it's very funny somebody won the
Scottish Open before that four years
before that guy by the name of Wayne
Riley and he had a three shot lead
playing 18 and he did what everybody
says Van Pelt shooter done he did take
an iron off the tee and a layup second
shot and a wedge third and two putts and
made five and he won one by a couple of
shots supposed to advance both did it
it's one of the most unique things that
I would love to see if somebody's in
contention on Sunday and they have to
make the choice do I layup or do I keep
with the game plan that got me here
fascinating because you can't keep Van
de Velde out of your mind
can't do it but you also have a course
that's been playing pretty fast you guys
had rain this morning there and you know
somebody's gonna have driver on 18 and
you know want to bomb it there so I mean
we might have some drama because of how
fast that course has been I don't know
what it's like now but it's I mean it's
a little tamer than it was but you know
I think the rains done for the weekend
I'm looking over here to the west
there's brighter skies the winds a
little bit of a breeze I think it's
gonna get back to firm and fast as we go
through the weekend here's the problem
with driver you want to play driver
that's great the balls gonna get caught
up in the rough if you miss I'm looking
at a guy right now Eric van Hawaiian who
actually had a good day yesterday so the
first page of the leaderboard
he just missed 18 to the left and he got
caught up in the thick grass it kept him
out of the burn and he's have no layup
so now he's gonna have to try to make
five and it's not an easy green so you
can lay up okay i'll lay up six six is
easy to make no matter how hard and fast
these fairways are so that's that's the
problem this is as good a finishing hole
as you see in a major because there is
so much fear in every player no matter
how well you're playing what's the
cutline gonna be looking like three and
Dustin Johnson and Justin Thomas are
probably gonna miss I don't think it's
gonna get to four if it gets the floor
over Justin would make it so number one
and number two in the world are probably
going to miss the cut and that hasn't
happened that it open in seven eight
years really five seven years 2011 I
think was the last time that happened so
given that there's still a bunch of guys
on the leader board in no position of
players who've won majors before we're
gonna have a a good chance going into
the weekend here finish this sentence
the more I see of Tiger Woods the more
convinced I am what watching somebody
make progress we're not watching a guy
who's gonna win six more majors I mean
hey guys she's gonna be 43 here in
December you know we talked about jacket
46 and Mickelson contends all the time
but nobody wins that many majors and he
Tigers not gonna do what he did back in
his heyday I mean it's silly to think
that can he win majors again yeah this
is probably the best one because today
he didn't hit many drivers it was a
position and patience game and he played
okay shot even par it could have been a
little bit better but overall he played
pretty solid I think we're just watching
him build confidence in these bigger
events and stack healthy rounds on top
of healthy rounds so to make a cut here
and be a part of the weekend not really
in the mix where he's probably gonna win
but have a good chance to finish top 15
top 10 I think from where he was that's
that's a good finish as far as I'm
concerned I I think they think he's
gonna come out win major championships
now is a little bit of a failure to dust
off reality and live it in the past are
you gonna play the golf course no I'm
coming right home too much summer summer
left yeah I have you played Scotland er
you put Ireland a bunch I've played I
played some in Scotland but I didn't
play Carnoustie yeah I play st. Andrews
yeah I played four or five of the
courses in the rota
over the in the 20-something years of
coming over this is by far the hardest
Frank Nobilo said it best on the air
today there are bunkers in places you go
and then you play it the next day and
the wind turns around it's 25 in your
face you go oh that's why they put a
bunker 210 yards because I can't reach
the fairway the design here is so cool
I wish American design would pick up a
little bit of these things is this burn
that Vandevelde put it in and all that
stuff it's seven yards wide it snakes
around seventeen and eighteen and one
and you're thinking about it for about
six or seven shots as opposed to a big a
big pond with a funky fountain and go
this is great this is really neat I I
much prefer the way these courses are
designed for my golf main most famous
person you play golf with the president
what's fun I played golf Trump I played
golf before he was president I played
golf with Donald Trump Jon Gruden and
Ron Jaworski the first year or second
year that that was our Monday Night
Football booth jaws had a relationship
with the Trump because joslyn's cos golf
courses in South Jersey and Philly Trump
at his casino so there was a
relationship there so we get up to the
practice tee and jaws Gruden and I are
up on the practice ground and Trump
comes up and he looks at us and he goes
all right it's me and Gruden I'm taking
the champ
I like winners quarterback in the Super
Bowl John did was coach I like where's
I'm taking the champ here so actually
the funny story for that was Gruden
rented clubs of that Trump's course in
Jersey guru said I love these clothes
Trump said they're yours it was it was
quite a day there are legendary stories
of Trump and golf I can't say it he is
still for his age at that times in his
mid sixties had a good swing good turn
he still does and was a very key clutch
putter he could make a big putt from
anywhere on the green and putted it
really well how is Gruden John John
John's good John was a quarterback at
Dayton so he's a good athlete still e
when he when he wasn't coaching he was
gonna playing golf probably on you know
one one time a week or so with his dad
who was
so a coach back in football days but
Judge John can get drunk and get the
ball out there and as you would expect
this is a little competitive in Johnny's
bring it was fun to play golf with Mike
I never got the Chucky Chucky stare if I
missed a putt and I was his partner but
John was pretty good have fun there Mike
by the way Seton in our draft we had a
three round draft or round draft Seton
traded jordan Spieth for Alex Norns
straight up yesterday mid-round I do
that but norm pretty good he's top 12 in
the world who has Fowler hey Ricky
McLovin does yeah he's keys cash and
foul it's gonna win this week so I'm
with you okay
all right because yeah we had our draft
yesterday and I don't think there were
any surprise any surprises yesterday I
don't think so oh did anyone take Tiger
yeah McLovin did okay good I respect the
omage history it's good
somebody took Zach Johnson - how about
that seat seriously yeah it was the
Danette and you saw was that what 15
picks Oh 20 there's five of us go around
for yeah 20 picks and Zach Johnson won
Wow
yes who made that pick Seaton did let me
know if you need me to fly out like yeah
yeah he's an expert right okay joining
me now here at 18 Justin Leonard was
supposed to be here no Tom Lehman it's
gonna be C fairway Jesus went pretty
high too oh really yeah tell me
Fleetwood yeah don't leave me well of
course I didn't know that was his
nickname but that was my assumption
based on the hair yeah who else when I
had a Francesco Maddon ami I took him
good take Dan it's a good pick they've
worked on this putting great ball
striker
very solid it'll take on the bunkers I
like that even though he dropped a
couple shots towards the end today no no
bummer is this is just
pay for the win or we know you you cash
whatever they make that you you get your
total whatever they okay they total up
there yeah total McCool yeah fun by the
way by the way last who did I have at
the US Open I had Brooks koepka Tony fee
now right Patrick Reed Patrick Reed OC
crusted in the top 10 yeah oh my gosh
yeah
so if I can help you in any way or this
show can help you guys cuz I don't know
if you have enough experts over there
but we can help you with show prep like
you know what I will drop in some point
over leaderboard Seaton's pick now may I
know you can do it on the Golf Channel
mic just you know you're they're not
gonna let you do it on NBC thank you the
next three hours so they go back up
there without those yeah just just throw
it out there that you know there's a you
know controversial Alex Norton trades
yes Seaton O'Connor who traded bring
that up to Nick Faldo you know earlier
today scene O'Connor for the damn
Patrick Leahy he traded jordan Spieth he
got Alex normal do tell neck we said
alone Mike will be will be watching
thanks buddy Mike Tirico NBC Sports Golf
Channel host and they got coverage till
4:00 Eastern today Golf Channel and then
Golf Channel and NBC coming up this
weekend for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]